well when you went public because you
took the wwf public right
and your whole media entertainment
empire whatever that is whatever that is
whatever that is whatever that is i
don't even know if you know what it is i
probably don't
right but i'm saying when you go public
and everything you don't get to
the next day cash out all your stock no
definitely not
right so so what would be a good thing a
billionaire
right are you a billionaire i don't know
you are it sounds good
is it amazing to think that you know i
remember even when i used to watch you
when wrestling first started you know to
take off again and had its resurgence
because of you
i would say i never thought of you as i
thought you were the announcer i didn't
even know you were the owner of the
of the wwf i just thought you were the
announcement you were always the owner
were you
no definitely not yeah and my dad
actually
your dad owned it yeah my dad owned 50
he had some other stockholders was your
dad a millionaire
probably not and then you took it over
and how old were you when you got it uh
late 30s early 40s and how long did it
take before
you really went around that rocket not
long i mean you know
actually you know my dad see they had
like little territories
you know back in the day and my dad's
territory was the northeastern territory
and he was very successful actually and
my premise was that what my dad sort of
started in a more entertainment genre
you know would be successful all over
the globe so and no one ever competed
with anyone else
you never crossed into the other guy's
territory type thing so you had a
brainstorm and you knew how to market
this thing that's why they call your
marketing genius
yeah i was looking through the notes i
guess it said that vince has said that
if his dad ever knew that he was going
to take
national he probably wouldn't have given
it to him well yeah that was because my
dad had a lot of friends these other
you know territory owners that owned
these fiefdoms you know right they had a
lot of friends in the queens
so in other words you crushed these
people
and not competed with them and you won i
mean
big deal that's what you do in business
sure yeah why not
my dad was not too thrilled with that at
first though and and your dad
your dad has since died right yes he's
no longer alive you got brothers and
sisters
uh yes i have a brother in texas texas
is he in the wwf no nothing to do with
it what does he do
he's in the steel letters no no no no no
please borrow some money vince
that's what he does all day he's in the
steel business somehow is he wealthy
he's stealing i thought you were the
steelers
is he a wealthy guy i think he does all
right right do you are you in touch with
him oh yeah sure oh you are you're close
with him yeah
he doesn't show you his bank account
right no so so
when you're when you make this kind of
money what what is it you do with this
money i mean
do you buy homes are you a charitable
guy i mean what do you do
i really i think you do you know i mean
i can't speak for anyone else
goes out and
you know but other than that i mean you
get up like everybody else and you know
and you go to work i mean
i love what i do i you know so i never
really
have a big mansion every guy i know well
wait a second every guy i know
who makes the kind of money you make
they all say the same thing
i'd keep working anyway you actually
love what you do i love what i do
you know the people who don't go to work
when they have this kind of money
the kids yeah but you love what you do
and yet
i gotta think on a day-to-day level at a
certain point in your life it starts
i'm not saying you lose the eye of the
tiger but you start to kind of feel hate
there's more i could do with my life no
i
i guess that may come you know i mean
the aggravation factor it it may be
there one day but it's not there yet i'm
55
and it's not quite there yet so i mean i
just love what i do
in all aspects if i work for you and i'm
a wrestler am i allowed to come to you
and say hey
vince i want to raise absolutely i am
actually to you he doesn't go through
somebody else uh actually the younger
guys would go through somebody else
you know but the guys that have been
around for a while you know i mean
you're still talking oh yeah because you
because you dealt with them you dealt
with them in the beginning absolutely
you're getting older now right you're
considerably wealthy have you sat down
with a lawyer and said who is going to
inherit your empire what are you going
to do
oh sure you know who's going to take
over the whole thing is shane your son
going to take over
shane stephanie marissa make those kids
work together for the rest of their
lives
absolute partners and how do you think
that'll work doesn't there have to be
one person in charge like you always had
the ultimate say
right and haven't you seen these
families where the kids start
fighting and sure everything is
definitely i don't think it'll happen in
my family but
you know you know everyone's always said
that you know but
you know but they're both in the
business you know and they both love the
business and
and you know i think that they'll
they'll work it out you think that
they're capable because i know a lot of
guys who own businesses they try to pass
them off to the kids right and secretly
somewhere deep in the heart they go geez
these kids don't have what it takes
they're going to mess it up actually
shane and stephanie are a lot brighter
than i am so
really yeah and you feel that they can
handle it and your will
you will leave everything to shane
stephanie and of course your wife
right is that how it will work sure i
would love to be in on that
yeah go ahead actually before you said
i'm going to leave everything to shane
stephanie and marissa
marissa's actually his daughter-in-law
does she get an equal share even though
she's not a blood
no way i'm stepping in on that there's
no
way no freaking way it's marissa there's
johnny come lately
she's beautiful unfortunately she's a
little sick today she is yes she's sick
because she's not getting the money
and that's why she's no i don't think so
oh i think so
yeah right congratulations on all your
success and i love that you came here
today that was great
thank you very much very nice to meet
you and i would like to own a team in
the xfl and
keep wishing